monsieur messika bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors un
confinement qui on vient de le voir ne
fait pas l'unanimité surtout en cette
période de fêtes sera vraiment très
difficile pour les familles de se
retrouver alors comment interpréter
cette décision
tout simplement parce que le premier
ministre essaye de prendre des décisions
de manière collégiale il ne fait pas
tout seul il emploie un certain nombre d
un certain de personnes autour de lui il
ya des scientifiques qui sont la guerre
ça mais on est dans un pays déjà où il
ya 2 8 kg à 3 opinion alors imaginez
dans un problème comme celui là où on a
du mal à savoir effectivement ce qu'il
faut faire c'est pas du tout évident
donc les gens qui crient dans la rue que
j'ai plus dans notre reportage juste
avant qu'ils oui mais ne font rien pour
nous aider c'est ça c'est pas un signe
évident que ça y'a pas et c'est pas une
solution en plus sera égale 2 sait
quelque chose lui qui tient en compte
des loups gris de paramètres par exemple
on voit qu'en suède
les choses ne sont pas du tout passé
comme de ce n'est le préserver leurs
frères et comme le scénario qui se passe
en france qu être quasiment dans chaque
pays il ya une problématique tout à fait
différente donc accusé le premier c'est
un peu ce que je trouve que c'est un peu
léger non effectivement comme vous dites
c'est pas mal
et parce que justement il ya tellement
de d'hypothèses qui sont émises par les
scientifiques eux mêmes qui disent une
chose et leur contraire que c'est
complètement c'est pas du tout évident
de prendre une décision
la décision qui a été prise c'est
justement ce qu'on appelle ses gains si
c'est à dire le confinement leur
confinement si vous voulez avec un
certain nombre de mesures comme la non
possibilité de dépasser 500 mètres voire
un kilomètre à partir de chez soi
toute la partie on va dire qui concerne
les écoles qui vont être fermées pas de
réunion à plus de 10 dans un lieu
au privé par contre dans un lieu public
ouvert on peut aller jusqu'à vingt
restaurants qui vont être fermées les
hôtels qui m'ont affirmé lacoste
rencontre fermée avec mais avec la
possibilité de faire du take away c'est
dire donc des livraisons enfin il ya
énormément de choses et c'est vrai ou
que c'est très contraignant mais c'est
aussi le rôle d'un dirigeant d'un pays
de savoir prendre de décision même s'ils
ne sont pas populaires alors du point de
vue économique on sait qu'israël a du
mal à se remettre du premier confinement
le taux de chômage touche déjà 20% des
actifs
le gouvernement at il était à la hauteur
de l'ampleur de cette crise sanitaire
selon vous alors il faut savoir que vous
dites qu'il atteindra pour cette raison
qu'il faut savoir que au début du duduk
du deuxième conflit il atteignait les 40
45 % là maintenant on est remonté à 80%
malheureusement il ya toujours
énormément de gens qui sont contaminés
avec ça c'est ce qu'on voit
effectivement dans les dents les
vérifications dans les dents les dans
les tests qui seront effectués
aujourd'hui le test qui apparaît nous
montre qu'on à 5238 de personnes qui ont
été contaminées hier donc c'est quand
même relativement importante
alors au niveau économique il qu'israël
était dans une bonne situation avant le
confinement
ce qui fait que aujourd'hui on arrive
une scène finances arrive à surmonter il
faudrait pas que ça dure trop trop trop
longtemps encore
non depuis passeront par pas sur des
prévisions optimistes
on se dit ce ne sera pas avant la fin de
l'année prochaine on a trouvé
effectivement un pas que ça et qui sera
opérationnelle vers novembre mais on
pense être toujours dans la même
situation jusqu'à la juste qu'à la fin
de l'année maintenant est ce que le
gouvernement était à la hauteur je pense
que c'est ça que je voulais vous dire
qui est très important c'est que d'abord
il ya effectivement ce confinement
mais parallèlement on a un espoir ici
dans mon pays le pays s'ouvre et on est
en train de signer des accords de paix
extraordinaire avec le bahreïn et donc
les émirats arabes unis ça s'est passé
hier
ça s'est passé la semaine dernière
c'était absolument improbable donc on a
cette impression qu effectivement être
confiné combattre monde reprend
conditions nous mêmes et pendant ce
temps on voit que notre pays
au bout de 70 ans arrive à faire la paix
avec ses c'est que vous vous réagissiez
un petit peu sur ces manifestations qui
sont présentes en israël on a vu le
peuple qui est en colère contre les
nouvelles mesures sanitaires mais
également contre benyamin nétanyahou ils
réclament la démission du premier
ministre est ce qu'il est encore l'homme
de la situation
écoutez moi je pense qu'au contraire il
est en train de faire un travail
excellent puisque il est en train
d'ouvrir les horizons qui était
complètement fermée pour nous c'est
qu'on cible au physique du virtuel au
sens figuré c'est à dire que les
horizons s'ouvrent pour israël
aujourd'hui binyamin netanyahou
on gagne énormément de deux ça aura
grâce à ces accords que nous avons de la
semaine dernière maintenant est-ce que
kiki qui réclament la démission mais ça
l'est
vrai pour tous quasiment sauvés magna
mais netanyahou donc il est encore voilà
la justice doit encore statuer
alors vous savez la semaine dernière je
sais que vous n'êtes pas un obstacle
on peut pas savoir ce que je vais vous
annoncer la il ya eu un tremblement de
terre au niveau journalistique un
journaliste très connu sahel qui
s'appelle hamid segal qui a dévoilé que
toutes les affaires contre le communisme
on était quand est que dès que des
supercheries et c'est un van gogh terme
journalistique et là en fait la machine
est pourtant complètement de se tourner
puisque l'on est en train de se rendre
compte qu'il y avait un véritable
complot judiciaire qui a été organisée
autour du courant gaulliste
bon je sais que c'est assez difficile à
croire pour pour des gens qui sont en
france qui suis-je palatine l'actualité
liestal et qui ne savent pas
effectivement de quoi et accuser de
communistes mais sachez en fait que très
bientôt vous allez en entendre parler
c'est déjà sorti dans la copie nationale
la semaine dernière c'était mardi
dernier c'était un tremblement de terre
politique
un tremblement de terre journalistique
un scoop extraordinaire qui l'a amené
donc je peux vous dire que les choses
sont un petit peu après le chargement
madania ou et de son image de marque
merci beaucoup monsieur habillé messika
d'avoir réagi sur notre antenne sur la
comète analyste politique